oh good um I just got a question real
quick why do you talk like with such
confidence about Islam when in reality
You Don't Know Jack about it well if
you're saying that I don't know Jack
about it prove that I Don't Know Jack
about it man okay you just told some guy
that the Quran doesn't isn't called the
Criterion when there's a whole chapter
called
when starting off finish you're starting
off FS I'm trying to help you I never
said I never said that the Quran is not
called the Criterion in fact I I
literally said that the Quran is called
the Criterion in the Quran but also the
Torah is also called the Criterion
that's what I said I was addressing
specifically chapter
5:48 where the Muslim was trying to say
that the Quran is called the Criterion
in that verse and it's not that's what
was corrected okay but the whole point
and what you guys you and that guy were
saying after was like okay yeah that
dismantles the whole argument quote
unquote that the Quran is the supreme
authority over the other scriptures you
said that which means you saying that
about the the Quran the the Quran not
being a Criterion that verse you told
that guy you made him believe that oh
yeah that means that diss the whole
argument you don't mention no oh it's
mentioned other places I've been here
since that whole time you didn't mention
there's a whole chapter called the
Criterion you didn't mention none of
that You Don't Know Jack bro and you
here it sounds like what I said one ear
out the other so this what I'm gonna
give you a chance to do I want you you
said it so show me where show me where
the Quran is called a Criterion over the
previous scriptures show me that verse
in the Quran I don't have to show you
nothing ah you don't got to show me
nothing no don't I'm not I'm not I'm
notna go in and out I'm not goingon to
go in and out the screen for
the J you don't gotta show me nothing
see I told you when you come up here I'm
let you speak around no notice I'm gonna
let you speak notice how when you come
up here and you say that I don't know
Jack squat right and you say that I'm
wrong about something and I give you the
opport opportunity in front of 700
people to show me where I'm wrong and
the thing that you say your best thing
that comes out of your mouth is I don't
have to show I don't have to show you
nothing I don't have to show you nothing
brilliant brilliant absolute
magnificent just brilliant you got to be
kidding me man so I think that what you
just proved is That You Don't Know Jack
Squad
and you can't show me nothing cuz I'm
your teacher mate I'm the shake I'm your
teacher bro okay okay so okay I don't
even realize all 700 people you could
look at the viewers I'm here talking to
you I came up here I asked you a
question and talk to you
about one second one second you just
wasted four minutes of everybody's time
mocking me because I refuse to answer
respectfully waste my time just go go
you talking about wasting time bro you
don't okay so then show me the birse bro
I just told you I don't have to show you
jack I came up here bringing something
up and you trying to change the topic
you over here try to deceive another
Christian you just you deceived another
Christian hold I was just about to kick
you outan but you sa you dece you
deceived another Christian you said that
I'm changing the topic go ahead go ahead
you said that I'm changing the topic yep
what what was what was the topic that
you addressed me on the topic was
proving that you don't know about Islam
but you and what was the example that
you gave that you deceived another
Christian on the Quran not being the
Criterion of the previous scriptures
right yes the Criterion what so so if I
ask you show me in the Quran where it
says it is a Criterion over the previous
scriptures isn't that addressing exactly
what you said no that's addressing the
second topic the first topic was How You
Don't Know Jack about Islam that's it
all right thanks for coming
you're a joke to be thanks for coming
you remind me of Muhammad man in a good
way my question is to you is why you
think it's okay to come out in a
religion and say your religion is false
right do you think that's okay yes and I
know you want to say oh you you think
it's okay okay so I said to said to you
that your religion is false how would
you feel I would feel excited because
that would mean excited okay yes and let
me tell you what I would feel
excited let me tell you why relax dude
the reason why I would be excited is
because now that is an opportunity for
me to show you why my religion is true
I'd be excited if you came saying that I
mean for me respectfully I would not let
anybody talk crazy about my religion and
it's not like I'm trying to fight them
also I don't want to say that I
represent the Muslims
Mo disagreeing disagreeing with a
certain religion is not talking crazy
about
if you believe my religion is false you
believing my religion is false is not a
disrespect no but the way you do it is
that you come into this Tik Tok and you
want to express your belief and then
you're going to go around bringing in
people who are not as knowledgeable as
other people are on the religion so
you're going to question them they can't
answer your questions and then you going
to embarrass them proving your point
except you were dealing with people who
are not you know who don't study the
religion like you do you study your
religion all the time you try to find
the the ways to make a Muslim be wrong
when you the only thing I do bro is I
I've studied Islam and I share Islam I
spread it and I and I teach Muslims
Islam and you know even with the people
who are so-called knowledgeable they're
they're sitting actually in the Comon
section as we speak but they're not
coming up they don't come up there's a
thing that we in Islam
is that when it's it's best you do not
argue with somebody even though you're
are right just don't argue with them
because it's not worth it what do you
mean argu argue because you they you
trying to prove a point to them it's
best you don't try to prove your point
even though you know you're
right best that I it's best that I prove
my point so that you can be no I'm
talking about in Islam my boy I'm
talking about in Islam that's why you
not how many Muslims want to argue with
you because they don't want to deal with
you as you see Mo as you see I have a
large Muslim audience and I get Muslims
every day all the time that want to talk
to me what are you talking about cuz cuz
I'm talking about Islam not Muslims stop
talking about Muslims coming in my BL I
said yeah let me show you the Quran
literally says to discuss with the
people of the book in a good manner
you're supposed to talk to me in a good
manner about our scriptures and about
the Quran we're supposed to have these
discussions hold I said I'm not talking
rude based off I'm not saying nothing
rude about your religion but I'm just
saying that you over here talking about
these Muslim oh you just cursed me in
Arabic yeah I did I'm not GNA lie that's
how getting tight why' you do that I
don't even worry about it don't even
worry about it don't worry about it
don't even worry about it I say I'm
confused because you you came up here
you know saying why am I talking crazy
about Islam and the Muslims but I
haven't cured you I haven't said
anything but you cursed me for some
reason why okay okay I just want to say
this one thing do not try to make this
oh now Muslims are disrespecting me do
notes I'm not even going to say that
because the previous Muslims that came
up before you they've actually been
pretty respectful but you
you yo bro cuz you he what I said do not
try to make me look like I represents
Muslims in the bad
we I'm talking to you specifically Mo I
literally just said that
the stop for a second I literally just
said that the Muslims that came up
before you for the most part were
respectful but you came up and you're
disrespectful so I I I literally
separated you from the majority that
I've dealt with today okay so my
question is why exp why' you curse me
out because it's normal to curse out
people in New York in New York you can
go to New York they'll curse the hell
out at you it's normal it's not so it's
not you
can't is that a good thing it's not a
bad thing but it's not a good thing it's
it's not a bad thing to curse people out
it's not a bad thing cuz some people
need to be cursed out some people need
to learn how to shut the hell up so in
Islam you're allowed to curse people out
because it's a good thing sometimes I
never said in Islam you okay now you do
now you just you know switching my words
out I never said in Islam I'm talking
about New Yorker I'm talk about like New
York according to Islam is it good to
curse people out no so then why are you
cursing me out if it's not good good to
Islam i s I'm a human I'm a human I sin
the heck Muslim don't sin well guess
what you just you sin against me right
okay and I ask God for forgiveness well
no you're you're going to have to ask me
for forgiveness on Judgment Day I ask I
I ask for God no you're gonna have to
ask me you're you're gonna have to right
how you want to think no that's what
your religion teaches you're going to
have to make it right with me before
before you make it right with Allah you
didn't know that
uhuh so I you better make it right right
now apologize I'm sorry for the for cing
at you I don't forget you so now Allah's
going to send you to Hell well he St
your only hope is now to come to Christ
see if you come to Christ he'll forgive
you no matter what I say but if you stay
in Islam you're going to hell cuz I
don't forgive
you your only hope is to come to Christ
because regardless if you go to Christ
and trusting him for your salvation
he'll forgive you whether my heart is
hard against you or not but in Islam
you're stuck you going to
hell become a Christian
buddy we got
him we got
[Laughter]
him oh my gosh
man oh this is this is too fun